Hello, this is Dr.
Palmer. I am recording
Systemic Rheumatologic
Diseases. This is part
two of the three-part
rheumatology lectures.
We are going to talk about
rheumatologic diseases that
affect the general system,
the general body. These
could be multiple systems.
They are not just joints.
so at the conclusion of this
course we should be able
to describe the presentation
and diagnostic criteria
used to diagnose lupus
specifically systemic lupus
erythematosus we are going to
describe the different uses
of ANA testing remember we
introduced you to the concept
of ANAs in the last lecture
we are going to talk
about the presentation and
you should be able to describe
systemic sclerosis or
otherwise known as scleroderma
and describe the presentation
of Sjögren's syndrome.
Reminder of autoimmunity.
Remember the why
and the hows, the
genetic susceptibility,
breakdown of self
-tolerance,
environmental triggers,
leading to tissue damage,
the activation of self
-reactive lymphocytes, and
then further tissue damage.
So let's talk about
autoimmunity considerations.
We used some words
in the last lecture.
Some of those are
new words as far
as descriptions of
exams and findings.
Now we're just going
to use some other
consideration words. Chronic,
relapses, remissions,
progressive, and then systemic.
Now,
definitely rheumatoid arthritis
goes through is chronic,
has relapses, and remissions
can also have systemic
presentations, progressiveness.
I'm not saying that,
but again, when we look at
here, the words that we need
to be thinking about with
autoimmunity, these apply.
We need to consider the
nature of the underlying
immune response, and
then identify which
hypersensitivity reaction
this is. So, reminder,
hypersensitivity reaction type
2, antibodies bind to cell
surface causing destruction.
Type 3 is an immune
-complex antigen-antibody
-complement reaction.
So sometimes, simplistically,
as a physician,
we may describe autoimmunity
being where the antibody
is attacking directly,
causing destruction. But
that may not always be the
case. That may not be always
what's causing the
pathology. It may not be that
the antibody is directly
binding to the cell surface
causing destruction. It
could be also due to the
immune complex antigen
-antibody complement formation.
So we're going to talk
about lupus first,
systemic lupus erythematosus.
It is more common
in female patients,
specifically this age group,
17 to 55 group. There is
a genetic association.
You can see that the onset is
typically in the
ages of 20 to 40.
It is most common and
severe, more severe,
in African, Hispanic,
and Asian populations.
It is multi-organ
system disorder.
It's mostly the effects
are due to the antibody
antigen complex
deposition, so that type 3
hypersensitivity. It's found
in the capillaries of organs.
It is an autoimmune
inflammatory disorder,
autoantibodies to the
nuclear antigens. There
is a remission and
relapse cycle. It may
be mild and self
-limiting, but it can also
progress to life-threatening
and organ damage.
So a lot of those key
words all just came
up on this one slide
of applying to lupus.
There is a genetic
predisposition for BMT cells
specific for self-nuclear
antigens. And the idea behind
that is that there was
defective tolerance and
defective clearance of apoptotic
bodies. So not only when
you consider that the
autoantibodies are attaching
to something, but also
that genetic predisposition
is also a defective clearance
of apoptotic bodies.
Triggers for this could
mean things from UV light.
There's some medicines that
you may not have learned yet,
such as hydralazine,
propanamide, or D-penicillamine.
And again, we talked about
genetic predisposition.
We talked about
environmental triggers. Now,
considering the third
component is harm. And
again, those usually you
will see immune complex
deposition and the
binding of the antibodies.
and understanding these
principles can help you
understand how lupus is
presenting in a patient and the
things to expect from it
so this is just kind of
another picture of the
pathogenesis of lupus we talked
about predisposing factors
there's a lot going on
here I do not expect you
to memorize these kinds of
abbreviations for the HLAs
or anything in this one.
I'm not expecting the
previous lecture with
the other HLAs were
very important for here.
I don't believe you
need to know these. You
do need to understand
environmental triggers
as far as things that can cause
the predisposition
here. The epigenetics,
kind of understand this. Again,
this is connecting
your immunology.
So the predisposing factors
sets up for an abnormal
immune response. We talked
about T-cells, B-cells.
We talked about the
autoantibodies and then
immune complex. And then
we talked about deposition.
So, when we look at
the places that the
immune complexes can
deposit in, so you
may get rashes,
nephritis, arthritis,
carditis, and then
those depositions
lead to chronic inflammation,
related to renal failure,
cardiovascular disease,
atherosclerosis,
pulmonary fibrosis, ******.
You also have potential
for damage from treatment.
Presentations of lupus,
we talked about this is
systemic, so we're going
to have fever. We're going
to have the rash, the classic
malar rash, but there's
also discoid rashes. We
can affect the heart,
the blood, the joints, the
nervous system, and the
renal system. So findings
that we can see in each of
those, we've mentioned
the rash. You can get
pleuritis, pericarditis, you
can get low blood counts,
you can get a non-erosive
arthritis where we
talked about erosions
in rheumatoid arthritis.
Neurologic seizures
or even psychosis,
renal, you start by seeing
protein in the urine,
you can see cast, you can
see nephritis as well. And
you'll learn more about
those in your T-POM too.
So the classic
presentation of lupus is
with this malar rash or
also known as butterfly
rash and you can
see here on the face
all right um when it goes
away it's not going to scar
there's the discoid rash
as well that you can see
and these can be on other
parts of the body these
are just pictures of
um where they're on the
face and the hands um the
angry sun is you know you
remember we talked about
sunlight as a trigger.
I told you we're going
to see this picture
again. Again, when
we look at the joints
that are commonly affected
by lupus so we can
see these proximal
and phalangeal joints.
Again, OA, osteoarthritis,
rheumatoid arthritis,
psoriatic arthritis also
affects these joints.
And as we're piecing
together all these
differentials, I just
encourage you to go
back and just start
putting these together.
You know, these are
the, we've learned
about all these,
now we're learning
about the last one
here for lupus.
Hemochromatosis is not
going to be part of
this, but it is on the
list of differentials.
Again, remember, no
erosions seen on x-ray.
Lung involvement, we
mentioned pleuritis, you know,
those things can be treated
with anti-inflammatories,
pneumonitis may require
high-dose steroids
or immunosuppressants.
You can see a lot of
steroid use with lupus.
It can lead to more
fibrotic lupus pneumonitis,
which can lead to more
permanent scarring.
That scarring in the
lungs can increase
the pressure going
to the lungs,
which can increase
right heart failure.
When it attacks the heart,
An example here would
be Libin-Sax endocarditis
and this is a picture
of the mitral valve
and that's one of the
heart valves and you can
see where these vegetations
have attached along
the heart valve itself,
these depositions.
Renobalopsy, we talked
about proteinuria,
nephritis, you can see here
where we've got necrosis
due to that deposits.
Remember we talked about the
hypersensitivity reaction
where we're getting deposits.
Casts when you see that
there are, in the urine
where they're all
grouped together almost
like a cast of the inside
of the renal tubule.
So they come out as
a cylinder group.
Neurologic effects,
you've got to make
sure that you roll
out other causes
that it's not due to
actual medications.
that could be causing it.
And it could be anything from
headache, confusion, fatigue,
depression, seizures,
neuropathy. Now
let's talk about
laboratory testing.
So we've used the term ANA,
I've mentioned it before
here, anti-nuclear antibody.
So this is a type of
testing and it is very
much associated with lupus.
It is not very
expensive, it is highly
sensitive, but its
specificity varies.
When you couple it with
other diagnostic tests,
it really increases your
ability to diagnose lupus.
And specifically the two
here with lupus is the
anti-DSDNA antibody and
the anti-Smith antibody.
There are other ones such
as the antiphospholipid
and you can find decreased
complement, but when
we look at diagnosis, these
are the two main ones.
So, let me give you a
little bit about the ANA.
And this is just a
slide explaining how
the cells are incubated
with the serum,
with the wound out
ANA antibodies.
If the antibodies are present,
they bind to the nucleus.
It's detected through
fluorescent label anti-IgG
that reveals the anti
-nuclear antibody and
then that staining
gives a presentation of
either homogenous,
heterogeneous, how they
actually stain and that
pattern also matters.
So when we look at the
pattern you can see where
for instance here this
is homogenous staining,
and this is one
that's classic with
lupus where it's
double-stranded DNA.
You can see clumping in
B. It's more of a clumpy
pattern, and so this
one is associated with
systemic sclerosis, which
we'll talk about later.
C has a centromere pattern,
also systemic sclerosis,
but also found
in other things like
a primary biliary
sclerosis you'll
learned in Pupon 3.
It's also found in Sjogren's.
D is a nuclear
envelope pattern.
And then E is a coarse
speckled pattern. And then
this can also be found in
lupus systemic sclerosis.
And so looking at these
two patterns here,
and I want you to
just be aware of it.
I'm you identify this,
but when you order ANAs
in the real world, in
the clinical setting,
you're going to get
this stain pattern back,
whether it's homogeneous
or you're going to get
whether or not it's
speckled and such. So you
need to understand what
that pattern means.
So there's criteria
for lupus, an example
here. This is just an
example. I don't want
you to memorize this
in a preclinical state,
but we do need to understand
some criteria here.
So you want to find an ANA
at a titer greater than 180,
and if it's not there, then
we don't feel like they're
going to have lupus,
but if it is there, then
you go through here and
then you get points for
the following findings,
whether it's a
constitutional finding,
hematologic, neuropsychiatric,
eucotinous serosal,
musculoskeletal, renal,
and a phospholipid
antibodies, complements,
or the specific lupus.
Okay, so look at how many
points you get for anti
-DSDNA and anti-Smith
antibody. You get six points
for either one of those.
And again, you have to
have ten or more for that.
Criterias and things
over time have
changed, and this is
an example of one of
the common ones
that are being used.
Treatment for lupus includes
anti-inflammatories,
hydroxychloroquine,
corticosteroids,
immunosuppressants.
We want to identify
that this is lupus, have
confirmatory testing
tests for all the other
components. If we have lupus
nephritis, you refer to
nephrology as well. You
may have to do a biopsy.
Looking at
rheumatology consults.
Looking at checking the,
violating the heart.
Again, remember heart
disease is a concern.
Blood count, CBC.
And so this is just kind
of a pathway. I don't
want you to memorize
pathways at this stage,
but you do need to
understand the components of
how you're evaluating
and working up with this.
Non-pharmacologic treatment is
counseling and
support. It's a lot.
You want to have
multidisciplinary teams, so your
cardiovascular team, your
rheumatology team, and your
nephrology. We need to have
multi-system doctors involved.
We want to promote health
promotion. We don't
need other cardiovascular
disease to sneak up on
us when we just have
cardiac disease as well.
Avoidance of UV light.
We want to work on improving
exercise, weight control,
strength training of
muscles. We don't want
deconditioning to set in,
osteoporosis. And again, medicines
that we prescribe for
these have side effects.
We're going to move on
to systemic sclerosis.
It is more common in
female patients as well.
Onset 25 to 55 with peak
50 to 60 is typically more
earlier and more severe in
African-American patients.
And think of the
word sclerosis.
It historically was called
scleroderma. And this
is involving fibrosis
of the skin and internal
organs. So, we see the
skin in fibrosis, but
you've got to realize
that it also is causing
fibrosis of internal
organs. Hence the system.
Raynaud phenomenon is
present in almost all
patients with scleroderma.
The skin effects could
be localized, it could
be limited to specific
locations, or it could be
diffuse. We talked about
internal organs, and
those classically involve
the GI, pulmonary, heart,
muscles, and renal.
So, what is Raynaud's?
So, Raynaud's may
present with numbness or
tingling of the finger
and toes, but it's
really episodic
vasoconstriction of the
arteries and arterioles.
For phenomenon, you have
to consider that it's
secondary to other conditions,
while Raynaud's disease
is more primary and
idiopathic, meaning that we
don't know of it being
secondary to another
condition. That's typically
you're going to diagnose
that in younger women. It
also tends to be milder.
But as you find that, you
know, in an older adult
that's developing radons,
then potentially there's
another systemic autoimmune
condition going on.
And you can see that under
cold temperatures, you
can get that basic
constriction elicited where the
fingers and the toes will
turn pale and get cold.
So let's talk about the
pathogenesis of
systemic sclerosis.
So there's some sort of
external stimuli. We talked
about previously the
conditions for autoimmune.
We may not necessarily
always know what the
environmental trigger
is or even the genetics.
Sometimes we can
identify what's happening
within the immune
system, but we may not
necessarily be able to
identify all the causes.
So in this case, there's
some sort of stimuli.
It is activating, it's
causing, activating TNB
cell activation, causing
endothelial injury,
platelet activation,
this produces the
profibrotic cytokines,
and you get a persistent
response to a
fibrogenic cytokines.
so in this
synthesis leads to the
fibrosis of the skin and
parenchymal organs now
specifically in the lungs you
may get the lung issues
from just the proliferative
obliterative
vasculopathy and we're going
to talk about vasculitis
in the next lecture so
here's a question that
maybe excess collagen is
playing a role here as well
again some of this process
is just not well known
so there's condition
associated with this and it's
called Kress syndrome and
so you'll see the calcinosis
Raynaud's phenomenon
having esophageal motility
disorder sclerodactyly
and telangiectasia
and here's some
pictures of those
conditions the
Raynaud's, the calcinosis
the sclerodactyline
and the telangiectasia.
We talked about the
ANAs. Again, this is
going to be similar to
lupus. Very sensitive.
Specifically, this is
SCL70 and so you can
think of SCL, scleroderma,
sclerosis.
There's also the anti
-centromere antibody
and there's some
anti-RNA polymerase.
I bolded the common
ones that you may see.
The treatment
plans are based on
the systems that are affected.
So Raynaud's, if you're
experiencing Raynaud's,
the first step is
warming of the hands,
avoiding the colds,
gloves in the winter.
There's blood pressure
medicines called
calcium channel
blockers that can help.
If it's esophageal
acid reduction.
There are some oral
propionetic agents that have
been used. If it's
sclerodactyly, then you
work on OT, maybe surgery
if it was really bad.
If it's diffuse, then you
get into immunosuppression
with like metzotrexate,
cyclophosphamide,
IVIG,
or is microtuximab.
prednisone does not have a
role in systemic sclerosis
and it actually
is harmful and it
can increase the
risk of renal crisis
so again a reminder or
kind of a review of that
you're treating based
on the symptoms and the
organs affected, again
counseling based on the
systemic need and the
systemic disruption counseling
for support is important
nutritional support
and guidance because it
can affect the GI system.
Discussion of
prognosis is encouraged
with all patients
to assess them and
understanding
disease progression.
So we're going to move
on to Sjogren's syndrome.
It is still more common in
female patients than males,
50 to 60 approximately.
About half of them have
other autoimmune disorders.
It is a criteria
that's a salivary gland
inflammation from biopsy.
You'll see associated with
anti-Rho, SSA, or anti
-LA, SSB, antibodies.
And we'll look at that
table again coming up.
You'll find oral signs.
The clinical presentation
is oral signs or
ocular signs of dry
mouth and dry eyes. And
it has to be for at
least three months.
So I've got a dry mouth,
I've got dry eyes.
Think chagrins.
Okay. The pathogenesis of this,
the glands have some
inflammatory infiltrates.
T and B cells early
in the course.
It's dominated by B cells
later in the course.
There is an associated
with lymphoma.
Again, those exocrine
glands are what's targeted
here, the lacrimal and
salivary glands, but it can
also affect thyroid,
lungs, kidneys, and muscle.
Local terms to remember here
are keratoconjunctivitis,
sicka,
dry eyes, xerostomia
is the dry mouth.
There are the other
conditions that are
associated with rheumatoid
arthritis, renal's,
thyroiditis,
incursor with cyclosporine,
ocular for dry
eyes, pillocarpine,
prednisone, and avoid
atropinic drugs.
And this is just kind of
a person to think about
Sjogren's. They may
otherwise look healthy and
being normal, active,
involved, but they can have
other conditions and it
can affect their life.
Remember I said we
were going to look at
this table again. So
again, we We talked
about rheumatoid
arthritis. Well, they
can't have the ANA,
but now look at lupus.
Okay, pretty much everyone
has a positive ANA.
All right, let's compare
rheumatoid arthritis to
lupus where we get this
anti-double-stranded DNA.
Now, let's look
across this list here.
Anti-double-stranded DNA
really setting in with lupus.
Rheumatoid factor,
now, oh, look here.
See, this rheumatoid
factor we associated with
RA it can also be found
in these other conditions.
Look how high it can
be also in Sjogren's.
Anti-Smith
10-25% here have
is present in lupus,
but look at no one
else in these other
conditions have this.
The single-stranded
antibody A and B
is also present in lupus,
but look how much it
is in Sjogren's. So when
you're, like, comparing
and contrasting, you're
differentiating the
patients, you know, dry
eyes, dry mouth, if that's
all we've got, then
we're thinking Sjögren's,
okay?
Do we have renal
disease? Do we have the
rash? Do we have
other conditions here?
And we start thinking,
is this lupus?
Now, if somebody has
dry eyes and dry mouth,
and then, you know,
like I said, Sjögren's
can be associated
with other conditions.
We talked about
scleroderma and Crest
syndrome. Crest is
not to be nearly as
bad. Again, we're
seeing positive ANAs,
the anti-SEL for scleroderma.
There's an anti
-centromere antibody that's
more common in just
the limited version
of scleroderma,
the Crest syndrome.
The next lecture we're
going to talk about
muscles and polymyositis.
And you can see where
it can also have ANAs, it
can also have rheumatoid
factors, but there's
this anti-Joe here.
And we'll also talk about ancus
in the next lecture as well.
So, in summary, we're looking
at systemic autoimmune
disorders with multi-organ
challenges. A lot of them
are treated based on the
organs that are affected.
there are specific
findings in those tests to
help identify that there's
usually rheumatology
has check boxes so
certain things have to be
true to make the diagnosis
again part of that is
again we have genetic
predisposition we have environmental
triggers and we have to
find the signs of harm
and make sure you review
the the Scholar X.